the future has arrived and it is in the
shape of a transformer that can really
only transform into one other thing I'm
a nice fair with her and this is hashtag
new Slovak manufacturer aeromobil
revealed a new flying freaking car
prototype CEO arute Vakula said that he
hopes released in 2017 we finally
delivered on future technology promised
to us by the Jetson it's only a matter
of time before we get floating buildings
and sassy robot maids in love again for
the absolutely last time just like the
last one we need a minute series say
something sassy your shirt looks like a
sign for Japanese prostitution hey I'm
so sorry hey future unlike the silly
fictional flying cars that ruin the end
of musicals
the arrow mobile 3.0 is the real deal
with the ability to take off from and
land on airport runways and grass strips
you know in case you need to say
emergency crash land on a golf course
too soon why happened he was just
shooting a sequel to one of his movies
what yeah you know hole in Air Force One
because you have pollen 1 and Air Force
this is not funny or worth pocket that's
what his agent said and it back to
aeromobil
after decades of super boring
innovations like microchip that is ten
times faster than the last microchip in
making vaccines that are saving about
the people's live our world is finally
starting to look like that really can't
be future that they dreamt of in the
1960s flying cars wristwatches we can
talk to people colonizing the moon but
since it was in the 1960s it probably
these segregated moon colonies but still
moon Connie aeromobil CEO says that he
plans to sell the flying car to wealthy
super car buyers Oh so basically Jay
Leno
look I am far from rich I'm like dirt
poor but I think I could take it for a
flying car oh just taking a ride a nice
fancy aeromobil I think I will go to
Whole Foods and actually buy not just
eat samples like those commoners the neg
I will rub silk on my entire naked body
like us rich people always
but first a shower in my bidet you
obviously don't know anything about
being rich fine for those of us who will
never be able to afford flying cars or
aren't allowed to approach Jay Leno
because of a little restraining order
our cars will remain on the ground where
they belong for driving and living out
of you live in your car yeah yeah I do
that's it for hashtag news please like
this video and here is my question for
you in the comment box would you
actually take a ride in a flying car I
mean think about the drivers your mom Oh
becoming a pilot and fly me around
Oh No thank you do you guys like these
videos subscribe to new media rockstars
you guys what are all these buttons down
here we didn't put them there for fun we
put them lay out for you to click on I'm
gonna eat spare there and I might be
poor but at least I know that any car
can be a flying car if you try hard
enough
Oh No
[Music]
any